good morning John okay said that you had
to put a dollar amount on the value of a
human life
what would that dollar amount be the
easy answer is that you can't do that
it's immoral inconceivable its
incalculable the value of a human life
you know we do we the government of the
United States says that the minimum
amount that you can sell an hour of your
life for is $7.80 the average wages of a
person over their entire lives that's
about two million dollars so that's kind
of the value of human life but now it's
not that's the value of their economic
input wages are paid per hour but
they're just a surrogate for you know
value created for stuff made let's try
another angle raw materials really raw
materials raw organs is what I'm talking
about
uncooked sold on the black market if I
sold everything from my eyeballs to my
forearms I could rake in about five
hundred thousand dollars not bad I
wouldn't have much fun with it cuz of
how I wouldn't have eyeballs or forearms
but interestingly five hundred thousand
dollars is also the number that the
United States government pays to the
family of a fallen soldier by other
measures this is very low unlike working
advertising pays you for doing nothing
just for the presence of your eyeballs
in front of a screen
the average cost to serve a 30-second
television advertisement to a thousand
people is about twenty four dollars math
math math that's two dollars and 88
cents per hour multiplied by the number
of hours in your life if you sold all of
them this way that would be again about
two million dollars so if we only saw
the waking hours because advertisers do
not have the ability to advertise to us
in our sleep that would only be about
1.3 million dollars online video
advertisements on the other hand can go
for less than a tenth of that so there's
other reasons besides the fact that I'm
annoyed by them that we avoid pre-rolls
we just think they under value this
community's time why is your time
watching this video worth a tenth of the
time of a person watching a TV show I
don't know I think that's done but none
of this is how economist actually
calculate the worth of a human life or
of human time basically they do it one
or two ways the first is to calculate
the amount of money that someone has to
be paid extra to do a job that has a
certain risk of death so if there's a
job and it's dangerous like lumberjack
or something and there's a one in 1,000
chance that you're gonna die doing this
job and you say I have to be paid
$10,000 more to do that job than you
have just valued your life you have made
the decision that your life is worth 10
million dollars
statistically using this measure various
departments within the US government put
a value on a human life of about six to
nine million dollars second ways to
calculate not how much you would need to
get paid to risk your life but how much
you would actually pay to save your life
on the high end this comes in it around
one hundred and thirty thousand dollars
for one year of high quality non-painful
life so if you can extend someone's life
by ten years and those will all be high
quality non painful years that's worth
about 1.3 million dollars and for 78
years of high quality life that comes
out to a remarkably similar number ten
million dollars and they're into the
factory portion of the video now we're
off to the opinion II it might initially
seem crass or inhuman to say that there
is an economic value of a human life but
instead you should just say we should do
whatever we can to prevent death in
every situation but me there are
presents a kind of blindness to the
inevitability of death death has been
good enough for everyone who has ever
lived so far it's not the moment of
death where all of the value gets
created or lost to me the value is in
enabling the life all of the finite
moments that we have on this planet
together
it's not about preventing the death
which is gonna happen anyway
John this was supposed to be kind of a
silly video it ended up being a little
bit heavy sorry about that you were
fantastic on The Late Late Show and we
shall continue our discussion of how to
make online videos strong and awesome
as the years progress soon I'll see you
on Tuesday hahaha I was sorted by the
sorting hat in Pottermore
yes sorry I wear it with great pride
worthy huggers are you kidding I mean
we're ferocious and we're excellent
binders